and we are the cast of Daisy Jones and
the six and we're here with BuzzFeed to
find out which Daisy Jones character we
really are
take it away we do okay what is a
quality you look for in a best friend
honesty loyalty kindness supportive
optimistic good sense of humor I feel
like it's all of the event I think I
like good sense of humor I want a funny
friend I'm for honesty if you're my best
friend you got all the other ones anyone
who says loyalties oh it is best friend
it's not
yeah but imagine if they were just
honest yeah but I want to like shoot to
be around I'm gonna say kindness like a
70s song to sing it karaoke Dancing
Queen by Abba The Chain by Fleetwood Mac
okay Staying Alive by the Bee Gees yeah
that's pretty good Let It Be by the
Beatles Bohemian Rhapsody by Queen and
undertaking and try out where you lead
by Carole King Bohemian Rhapsody
oh oh okay okay you gonna let it be
we're supposed to shine
okay I'm gonna be eating Rhapsody I feel
like saying well in other words too pick
a legendary singer that you would love
to do it
it has
Beyonce wait Paul McCartney Dolly Parton
Prince Madonna and Harry Styles
I gotta go with Prince I mean that's
like obvious yeah I think it's Dolly oh
I'll do duet with the ghost of Prince
anything okay next one choose a daisy
Jones and the six character to be your
wingman who are they yeah
ride or die right to be honest I'm a
really good wing woman so many side cuts
Camilla yes thank you Ross who's the
tour manager Daisy Karen she's the
musician Teddy his dad
she's Queen you're like someone was
still the Limelight it's up to you Karen
is so sexual in the show she's always
like sleeping with people and like she's
just running off Riley's gonna black out
I know this is hard okay
yeah exactly yeah
look at what Simone did for Daisy
introducing Teddy I refresh by accident
I gotta lock in my eyes
I know what they were I know what they
were it's time to repaint the tour bus
what color color are you choosing we're
in between cherry red sunset orange
canary yellow sage green midnight blue
or bubble gum pink it was cherry red
let's be real Sunset I want orange juice
the canary yellow is very uncanary light
but who's gonna choose midnight blue
let's be real that's me bro
all right choose one of the 70s movies
to watch stars born Carrie that's Kramer
versus Kramer
during this movie night
but he's still wing man
with Paul McCartney as well as well
we're having a whale of a time
now pick a book to TV adaptation to what
normal people Game of Thrones Gossip
Girl Bridgerton big little lies or the
Queen's Gambit well big little lies
because Reese Witherspoon
[Laughter]
I'm fine
all these denim shorts
but you did wear some shorts at some
point I remember the famous Chicago
Stadium show Camilla's camera
you're a great photographer listen
okay Daisy's Journal Billy's denim
shorts
the famous Chicago Stadium show
Camilla's camera honeycomb the Aurora
album
and not the whole album I mean the show
wouldn't existence
without me shooting it so what do we
hope we all keep this one to ourselves
well my finger is ready three should we
do it
oh my God
your personality matches Camilla like
Camilla you are trustworthy intelligent
and a total badass you know your worth
and refuse to settle for anything unless
people admire you for your kindness the
air determine is like a biopic read more
read more but they also wish they had
your brains too you'd do literally
anything for the people you love that's
just the kind of person that you are
you're an all-around great person it
definitely doesn't go unnoticed yeah so
the three of us
four of us Eddie Roundtree your
personality matches Eddie like Eddie
You're motivated you're honest you're
attentive you're someone who is
dedicated to being the very best at
whatever you set your mind to you're not
afraid to speak your mind especially
when you know that you can fix a problem
you're someone who keeps their feelings
pretty close to their chest but you
would do anything
people you care about I love this this
is from Delhi that's really not right
daisy daisy daisy Jones your personality
matches Daisy like Daisy you're free
spirited creative and resilient people
are naturally drawn to your Magnetic
Personality and you never fail to make
people smile while life hasn't always
been sunshine and daisies
come on you know that your undying
strength is what's pushing you past the
Finish Line you're truly One of a Kind
thanks Daisy wow I'm aligned with what
they said this is a really wholesome set
of answers
I'm doing a speed retake yeah
[Applause]
it was the denim shorts for the swim
shorts your personality matches Graham
like Graham your empathetic ambitious
and loyal you're someone who wears your
heart on your sleeves and you'll do
anything for your friends and family
your incredible determination is
equality of yours that people admire
some people will describe you as someone
who falls for someone hard and fast
you're just someone who knows what they
want and will do anything together
wow whoever wrote these descriptions
thank you be sure to check out Daisy
Jones and the six on Prime videos group
hug guys
[Music]